okay we have had a continued explosion
with the David Pakman show
reddit I guess with people thing home a
lot of people are hanging out on reddit
we now have more than 18,000 of our
viewers and listeners participating at
david pakman.com slash read it a few
posts that caught my eye this morning a
article from CNN a group of young adults
held a coronavirus party in Kentucky to
defy orders to socially distance now one
of them has coronavirus you know these
these stories I mean listen I never take
pleasure in people getting sick getting
an illness having to be hospitalized
dying or anything like that
if these boneheaded decisions the the
decisions that come from minimizing or
even sometimes mocking coronavirus if
these decisions only impacted the
decision makers I wouldn't really care
that much like it you know I'm not gonna
be cheering that these these people
these young adults get coronavirus but
if they are the only ones affected by it
okay that's a decision that doesn't
affect anybody else but much like
secondhand smoke but to a much greater
degree they're having and spreading
coronavirus will get more people who
will not make it to be infected
it'll get older folks folks with
comorbidities who are more likely to die
infected so it's not fun and games it's
actually disgusting there are news
reports about teens coughing on produce
in grocery stores again the idea being
we don't care about coronavirus maybe
we're putting coronavirus on your granny
smith apple or whatever the case may be
and there's a lot of really great people
and inspiring behavior that this is
bringing out in our population and
there's also a lot of really disgusting
stuff that that is could not be more
vile and you know unfortunately this is
one of those things where if we're not
in it together we ruin it for everybody
it is it's sort of like a tragedy of the
Commons sort of situation where you
might not have much to lose if you get
coronavirus and so you benefit by just
doing your thing going out hanging out
whatever the case may be but that action
will hurt others and thus
hurt society in a way that in some way
probably will come back to hurt even
these young teens in any case you you
all know where I where I come down on
this we've got to just grin and bear it
and stay home and it you know thirty or
fifty states still haven't even started
doing that also from the David Pakman
show read it
HB 420 hosted biden leads Sanders by
eighteen and nineteen in two new polls
how do we blame the mainstream media for
this given that Biden has been AWOL
where's Joe and to the mainstream media
has been singularly focused on kovat
nineteen well it depends who you ask
there are people who say before all this
got going Biden was up eighteen or
nineteen now no one's talking about it
at all so Biden remains up eighteen or
nineteen now on the other hand there
continue to be you know a lot of the
folks that believe that during the
Bernie Biden debate Biden would implode
so ferociously that Bernie would take
the lead some of those same folks have
been saying Biden's done like two
streams about coronavirus and they've
been terrible where Bernie is doing many
more streams and they're good this is
going to flip the polling numbers it
just doesn't seem to be happening for
whatever reason and now the big question
is will there be any other debates as we
get closer to future primaries the one
if if primaries stop being postponed and
we were supposed to have one two days
ago in Georgia that's been postponed
Puerto Rico was supposed to vote in
three days that's been postponed I don't
know when the next actual primaries are
going to be Joe Biden is starting to say
I think we've debated enough Bernie
Sanders campaign saying no no debates
are good and we will see whether there
is any events that changes the
trajectory also the idea that
coronavirus itself will and many people
make it so clear that Bernie's health
care policy would be far better suited
to deal with a pandemic than that of Joe
Biden and that that will create a shift
in the polls we've been hearing that for
ten days and that shift has not yet
happened so I remain skeptical that we
are going to see that lastly from the
David Pakman show subreddit yes a user
named subbu Tai six one seven posted a
link to the infamous Ron Paul
coronavirus hoax episode that Ron Paul
did Ron Paul of course the father of
Senator
Rand Paul Ron Paul former Republican
congressman Rand Paul a current
Republican Senator Rand Paul now has the
virus
and Ron Paul previously called it a hoax
now it's important to mention if you go
and listen to that episode Oh Ron Paul
was not saying coronavirus itself is a
hoax like denying that it exists or
anything like that but he was of course
taking this kind of wacky libertarian
perspective about how the the kuroh
exaggeration of the hoax is the way that
coronavirus is being used to potentially
encroach on civil liberties and you know
the sort of standard libertarian talking
points still the contrast between Ron
Paul publishes an episode called the
corona virus hoax
Rand Paul gets the virus and then
continues hanging out at the Capitol
Hill at the Senate gym and other places
after being tested but before getting
his positive result not good and again
we can't listen to these people and I'm
glad that most libertarians are shutting
their mouths during this the
anti-vaxxers also are mostly shutting
their mouths that's a good thing
but I would expect that to start to
change if this becomes the new normal
and extends for many months which it
very well might join the discussion at
the David Pakman show
reddit david pakman.com slash read it
that's our e d di t